I can answer yes sir my name is my name
is Hoyer
my name is Blake and I'm fine mainly
flare up inside
no two
my mom looks like I'm nineteen year old
Joey in the boat three four five with
Travie seven or twenty or twenty nine or
doing and her brother learns what rule
six pin Europe 3445 my youngest grandma
is 55 I believe 49 hey Brandi I'm Jerry
nice to meet you glad to meet you all
right nice to meet you
I like your socks it's nice to meet you
[Music]
yep yep yep yeah you got it
yes for yourself hmm tell me you and how
old are you and then you called that 38
38 okay I'll take it
I think your sister gasps it's too hard
is why 39
why do you think I'd like a 39 yeah you
guys want to know how old I really am
yeah no no I'm 32 you were close
I'm really 18 so last gasp again so how
old do you think I am now hmm I'm 25
right mm-hmm okay I'm actually about to
turn 39 how did you know I am less
random guys telling you you play my real
age is 25 you go back and wear - how old
would you guess that I'm 25
yes Oh Blair and Blake how old am i high
five
you didn't say 50 I was worried about
this time flies when you're having fun
yeah one day - next time you 32 come
prank full moons she's done yeah guess I
need to be using better foundation I got
clocked by a kid
[Laughter]
[Music]